hi everyone this is a musician and
you're watching OTV my real name is Park
Macomb and I'm 21 years old and I'm from
Korea
I played picking first time when I was
five years old that was ps2 Tekken 4 and
I took taken seriously since 7 years ago
but I usually focused on enjoying rather
than winning
[Music]
[Music]
by influencing peckin is being every
time I play against him and news eilers
of the new options
[Music]
I love watching high-level players play
Tekken who have played only one or two
character the reason I chose Yoshimitsu
is I played all of the characters and
love he is the most dangerous character
also his movements are so cool like back
to one and ff2 so I chose him I think my
favorite match is vs. active but in LCQ
that was one of the big matches I tried
my best to win
[Music]
Oh
what's going on
dolly broke my footings I like my god yo
guess be careful to get old
Oh
[Music]
position oxygen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my best moment that I had in Tekken LCQ
that's my best result in twt
[Music]
there is an advice for aspiring
Yoshimitsu players find some cute moves
to enjoy and matter how to use that use
effectively
don't try to learn every moves in short
time you don't have to learn a lot of
moves in the beginning just have fun
times learning moves one by one and
joing is the most important thing in the
circle enter already like the 30 seconds
I can
Tom because 100 oz o Yogi's a little boy
they get everything is nice I didn't get
I'm
What's Up boss
Oh
[Music]
once again this is a musician you can
also subscribe to my YouTube channel and
find three by following the link below
the description thank you for watching
and be sure to subscribe to hotel bye
bye
[Music]
you